alexa show me people doing god's work
hail snyder i couldn't find it shut the
hell up man
so justice con has been going on all day
and it's actually managed to completely
overshadow comic-con
which is crazy when you think about it
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the exclusive clip that
was shown
and the panel with zach itself as
there's a lot to unpack
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
potentially ruined about the upcoming
hbo max release then i recommend that
you turn off now
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host definition
now let's get into our breakdown of the
clip and snyder's panel
okay so in the clip we see superman
meeting alfred
we did get this moment actually play out
in the deleted scenes for the theatrical
cup blu-ray
however snyder did state that there were
some things that this clip was meant to
represent
firstly it was that this will be his
version of the film
there will not be any compromises and
this tiny little teaser is meant to show
the realization of that
though it lasts less than 30 seconds the
idea behind it
is to show fans that due to all their
hard work and constant pressing of this
movement
his version is finally getting released
so
well done everyone pat yourself on the
back and hit that thumbs up button if
you don't mind as well now in addition
to this
he did state that this scene was shot
with the blue and red suit originally
as the studio aka warner brothers would
not allow him to use the black suit for
his version of the film
don't ask me why it was a strange time
where everything had to be colorful
however since his cut has been put back
into production
they have gone through the entire movie
and colour corrected all of the scenes
in which superman dons his suit and they
have changed it to the black and silver
one that we see here
it's a great little reminder of the
comic books namely the aftermath of the
death of the superman arc
in which suit done this costume black is
of course a color that's synonymous with
funerals
and this was put in place to show that
he was back from the dead
alfred is also there working on the
aston martin that was used in batman v
superman
when bruce went to lex's little
get-together getting out of this car was
actually the first time that clark saw
bruce
so it does kind of carry across from
that movie
i have no idea how this car broke down
but alfred's mechanic skills could also
explain why the batmobile has
a lot more armaments in the final battle
compared to what it did in the prior
movie
anyway that's the clip and pretty much
all i took from it
it was very short but longer than the
intercourse i've just had with my wife
so
who's complaining what now on top of
this we also learned a lot about the ins
and outs of the movie
and what would be happening in it snyder
went into the details over several
things
and it was a really interesting watch
i've linked the whole thing below
if you want to check it out and hey show
some love to the crew behind the event
now in the live stream he talked about
how visual effects were taking up the
majority of the time
with steppenwolf's design being a big
component of that
they did have previews of this design
around for a while
but it was of course scrapped for the
version that we got in the theatrical
cut
he did however say that he loved seeing
him come back and hey
i can't lie i love seeing him back too
in regards to stepping wolf's
motivations
they said all that he wants is for
darkseid to take him back
and he doesn't really care about
anything else thus the humans and heroes
are nothing to him
and the film will really add to how
intimidating he truly is
he will sustain that the cut was
finished all the way back in 2017
and that we're gonna see the giant
ultimate cut of the film
so yeah lots of things to get excited
about and for now the work is
predominantly taking place on the giant
cut of the movie
so we do know that we will be getting
everything including the kitchen sink
which i hope batman smashes over
superman's head
he said when the cut didn't look like it
was going to get released he always
hoped that a streaming service would
pick it up
so that they could distribute the entire
thing where people could pause it and
take it in however they wanted to
obviously with it being an almost four
hour film it would be very difficult to
show in theaters
so i think snyder's actually sort of
preferring that it's going to be
released this way
it also allows for the characters to get
their arcs and with nothing on the
cutting room floor
it's a complete cut now he still
couldn't confirm whether it would be a
full-length film
or be broken up into chunks and it was
teased that we would find out the exact
running time at dc
fandom they also address the title of
zack snyder's justice league
as due to rumors going around people
just don't know whether this is real or
not
they said that there were legal reasons
that were stopping it from being changed
and taking up another title which i'm
sure you know but
that they were working on it they also
discussed how the film was going to be
presented
and clearly the director has a lot of
love for imax
he said since watching bbs in imax he
realized that the added aspect ratio
really added to the film and he shot the
entirety of justice league
as if it was going to be shown on an
imax screen the theatrical cut of
justice league
was of course shown in full screen and
snyder has also been trying to bring
this aspect ratio over it is cut
rather than having the black bars along
the top and bottom personally i prefer
with movies for the entire screen too
as it makes it a lot better to watch on
tvs in my opinion
avengers was shot like that and i was
kind of good at that the other mcu
movies apart from ant-man
had the black bars on the top and bottom
which is just a personal preference
so clearly zack's in the same mind state
as me too and
it's great that we'll be getting an
incredible full screen image on
absolutely every part of the film
hopefully we also get a physical release
too because i'm a big 4k blu-ray
collector
and i'd absolutely love to own this as
i'm sure a lot of you would
they also talked about the new shirt
that the connor had used as a way to
raise funding for a lot of really
important charities
the shirt has an amazing update to the
logo on the front
and also associate producer on the back
with the idea that
everyone who got behind this movie all
of the fans
their producers on the film which i
think is a really great idea
and yeah it just gives back to us in in
a really astounding way
on top of this snyder confirmed whether
it was his decision or not to leave the
movie
and also whether it was him that had the
choice to pass it on to eden
he said that he and his wife deborah
were the ones that decided to step
back however it was a company decision
to pass it over to whedon
and though you know you can draw
conspiracy theories over that
he said they were really kind and took
it off his hands due to the personal
tragedy that was obviously happening
with him and his family
now in regards to re shooting scenes and
doing additional photography
he said he really can't talk on it at
the moment due to the pandemic
which has caused filming to be stopped
on a lot of things he also confirmed
that there will be more footage at
fandom
and hopefully this will be some more
clips or even a trailer itself
he did specify that the clip which we've
discussed already
was more for the fans that cemented the
realization of his ideas
lastly which is quite funny he did
specify
that he won't use any of joss whedon's
footage for his version of the film
he said and i quote i'd destroy the
movie
before i use a single frame that i
didn't photograph
that is the effing hard fact i'd blow
the effing thing up so yeah that's good
to hear
so it is gonna be his vision and that
was pretty much everything that you need
to know
and i just want to give a huge shout out
to everyone behind justice khan
for dropping such an an incredible event
it's one of the best examples of a fan
community coming together
and i'm sure many other people
appreciate you for putting it all
together
also thank you everyone in the chat for
showing me love yeah that meant a lot to
me
uh during the live stream and you're the
best now if you enjoyed this video
then please drop a thumbs up and if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
original ending for the movie
as well as everything that we learned
from the grace randolph interview with
zack
every month we give away free movies to
be able to subscribe to the channel
and this monty come in the mcu infinity
saga box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications
on the more videos you comment on the
more you have a chance of winning so
make sure you get involved
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of august and the set
will be shipped down from then to over
against the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part if you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
when you come chat to us after the show
either follow us at heavy spoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with us and thank you for staying
until the end
hopefully you see over there after this
but if not have a great weekend and take
care of yourself
much love peace
[Music]
[Music]
you